we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a comment about
my coverage of George Anthony devolder
Santos and specifically how I have sort
of taken a light touch when it comes to
his previous marriage to a woman
um in particular I've said there's a
long history of gay men who aren't
living as gay men publicly marrying
women
also the marriage to that particular
woman might have been an immigration
scam but anyway this caller says there's
something else I'm doing wrong in my
commentary take a listen to this
hi David
um I just have one little complaint
about your coverage of George Santos
please uh you talked about LGBT members
and gay gay men who are potentially
married to women uh to hypersexuality
but you've completely forgotten the fact
that bisexuals exist and are attracted
to both I would appreciate if in the
future you keep that in mind and don't
erase the b in the LGBT community I am
not erasing bisexuality in my coverage
of George Anthony devolder Santos he has
never asserted that he is bisexual if
that it I would just be Crow barring
that in for no we have no reason to even
consider that in the sense that Santos
has had every opportunity to talk about
his sexuality and he's never asserted
that so it's not about he's either I
mean I guess if you could take the
approach that if he's lying about his
his sexual orientation the truth could
be anything and that conclude bisexual
but I don't know why we would suspect
that in particular uh other than
um uh the the story of the immigration
scam which quite frankly seems like the
most plausible one to me at this time so
I would never erase bisexuality but uh I
also don't know why I would necessarily
insert it either we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today we are going to
talk about Senator Rick Scott
dropping his plan to cut Social Security
and Medicare despite the fact that he
spent the last two weeks claiming that
that plan didn't exist
but now he's dropping it but it also
didn't exist very complicated we also
are going to talk about one of the
greatest culinary lies in the history of
the United States the boneless chicken
wing the boneless chicken wing it
doesn't exist there is no such thing
there's no Wing in a boneless wing we're
talking about a piece of the chicken
breast or the tenderloin and we are
finally going to get to the bottom of
this culinary lie and also Ron DeSantis
is now looking to expand the death
penalty in Florida what does this mean
how is the Catholic Church reacting to
it a really interesting story about
Rhonda Santos that's not getting nearly
the attention it deserves so we will
talk about all of those stories and more
when I am joined on the bonus show by
producer Pat oh the bonus show where you
want to make money yeah everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad let's make that cash right Alex on
the bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a
discount I will see you then